Big Bungey has finally released his
Turkey Tom video to YouTube, guys. So,
we're going to take a look at that now.
Obviously, he's he's got more ads on the
screen. His His Patreon is down, as it
says. I think he got taken off Patreon.
I am encouraging you guys to to support
Bungey financially so you can see epic
videos like this weeks early before they
go on YouTube censored. See them
uncensored, too. So, that isn't that
awesome? Isn't that awesome? So, so make
sure you do support Big Bungey who's
providing this content that we're going
to basically freeboot today. So, let's
take a look. Let's see. Turkey Tom
video. It's called Turkey Tom and the
big elephant, okay? And I've already
watched it. I did watch the uncensored
version of Gamer Aid. I'm a huge fan of
this video. I was showing people it in
Discords and [__] I was like, you got
to watch this video. It's awesome. So,
we're going to watch it now. I I was
I've been begging him to put that on
YouTube. So, so I'm very excited. I'm
very excited, guys. Hopefully, you're
going to enjoy it, too. The commentary
community is coming to pieces. Augie is
gay. Nicholas Diorio is gay. Coal Blacks
is gay. Lyrics is also gay. Tommy C is
gay. And the final nail in the coffin,
Turkey Tom is gay.
>> It's over. He was the loser creep pedo
It's over. So, what happened here? Why
did the commentary community collapse
overnight? Two exes of Turkey Tom,
Sacramental and Katie, take to Kiwi
Farms to tell their tales of rape. He
was accused of three things: void
beatings and age playing with lolicons
on Instagram. The allegations of were
realistically the least bad thing. I'll
say this and the commentary community
would agree that if he was just a
I'd let it slide. But along with being a
rapist, he's also a bisexual and that's
realistically where I draw the line.
Let's get serious
>> Stolen joke from Miskif. Stolen joke
from Miskif. But that's fine.
>> moment here before everybody gets mad.
Turkey Tom is not a rapist,
unfortunately, but he is a homosexual.
Turkey Tom put out a big response to
this one. I'll sum it up for you. It's a
lot of more dick. It's a lot of more
dick. He goes over the allegations of
abuse. He goes over the allegations of
rape. But that's all well and good. But
me and the other rapists, we want to
know, what about the age play? What's
going on? Where's the response to the
age play? Because he gets to it and then
he just kind of says nothing and quickly
moves on. But before we can figure out
if this man ended up in a diaper, we
have to go back
>> Yeah. Tom All Tom said was basically
like, yeah, that's not true. That's not
true. Kai said that's not true.
Come on, bro. Come on, bro. and dissect
>> her entire life. Tom's first girlfriend
was a small girl called Kai and Kai
loved two things, neither of which were
Tom. Firstly, Lyrics. Secondly,
according to an anonymous Jewish source
pictured here, she loves diapers and
babies. So, Tom and Lyrics were in a
multi-year competition to win the heart
of this frankly sick and ugly woman by
gradually infantilizing their own
appearances more and more. So, Tom is
he's wearing like a Sonic the Hedgehog
hat and a Minecraft t-shirt.
>> And Lyrics, This is disgusting. This bit
is genuinely disgusting. little boys'
shorts. Before you know it, you've got
two grown men in shit-filled diapers,
not all of it there's, covered in baby
powder, lying on their backs crying. In
a last-ditch attempt to get Kai back
from this home-wrecker, Tom screamed
into the night sky and carved her name
into his chest. Didn't work, but on the
bright side, it could have been a lot
worse.
>> that. He did That's actually factual
information, I believe, that that did
happen.
Undeniably, that did happen. bit called
Cinderella. Kai also put out a statement
claiming that she's not into age play,
which I acknowledge, but I'm looking at
this video of her current boyfriend,
Lyrics, in little boys' shorts while she
flosses in the background and I'm having
a hard time believing that. However,
this scenario has had a severe
psychological impact on Turkey Tom,
giving him an obsession with BPD women
and also transforming him into a
profile. That's tongue-in-cheek. That's
tongue-in-chest, not an allegation. The
false allegations of rape unfortunately
dragged up Turkey Tom's relationship
with known lolicon age player, Creepy
Horder, on Instagram. I know what you're
thinking. Big Bungey, you're crazy cuz I
watched Top Sweeper, Nicholas Diorio,
and he said that the age play allegation
was just that the girl wore Sketchers on
him.
>> Dude, I did not realize how hard Nick
swept this. I didn't cover his Tom
coverage cuz it's like, well, the takes
are obvious. What can you really say? I
didn't think that he would actually just
like say a bunch of stupid [__] about
the age play thing for literally no
reason.
I I I
did not even conceive that that might
happen. I should have.
I should have, really.
Did not even consider it.
Instagram.
>> Katie L
>> It's like hot potato. He did age play
with her. No, he did age play with her.
No, he did age play with her. Wait, but
this Ellie person has a picture on her
Instagram where she wore Sketchers. If
the best you've got is that this girl
has a picture of Sketchers or whatever
the [__] or or what is it? Velcro shoes
on her Instagram, you've got nothing.
He's absolutely right about that. Here's
a picture
But that
is just so insane.
If you've even had a cursory look at
this girl's [__] Instagram [__] or
online posting,
it's so crazy, man. If the best Katie L
He just for no reason
defends like a highly documented like
lolicon local type character.
Like they've got There's a bunch of
insane A-logs that have so much [__]
that just proves you totally Why would
you say this?
Nick, why would you say this? It makes
no sense.
It's like hot potato. He did age play
with her. No, he did age play with her.
No, he did age play with her. Wait, but
this Ellie person has a picture on her
Instagram where she wore Sketchers. If
the best you've got is that this girl
has a picture of Sketchers or whatever
the [__] or
what is it? Velcro shoes on her
Instagram, you've got nothing. He's
absolutely right about that. Here's a
picture of her just for convenience. So,
yeah, she's just like a normal girl
wearing Sketchers. I mean, what red
flags could you possibly get? Here's
another one quickly.
Ah, yes. Really the dream girl.
>> So bad.
>> normal girl wearing Sketchers. You have
nothing. There's nothing amiss here.
What do you mean I'm a sweeper? What do
you mean by that? How dare you? How How
dare you call me a sweeper? This is
[laughter] Aiden Projects in a wig. This
is the
That doesn't look like Aiden.
You can't You can't deny the resemblance
to Aiden. the future of Aiden Projects.
I mean, if I saw this,
oh [laughter] mama. The baby's binky in
the background is really what pulls it
all together, I think. I actually can't
put this into my Google Doc. It won't
let me. It gives me an error. It gives
me a warning.
I mean, I think that bodes well.
Nicholas, put the broom down. Not only
is she not just a girl wearing
Sketchers, it wouldn't be too overdue to
say that she's sort of like the Chris
Chan of age play. She's incredibly well
documented.
>> want to say this.
What is this?
>> that Turkey Tom hangs out in. And this
is a good one, right? This is a good one
off her Instagram. In this post, she
says right here that she and her
boyfriend used to have sex where she
would pretend to be 9 years old and he
would pretend to be her rapist. And then
Tom has these DMs where he's like openly
saying that he knew she was like a weird
creepy age player and despite this, he
still sent her his dick on Instagram.
So, he went on to Instagram, he saw this
picture and he said, "I need to send her
my dick immediately." And Nicholas
Diorio, he's just telling me, "Don't
question this. Do not question But
please God, please God, don't question
it. She's just a normal girl. She's just
a normal girl wearing Sketchers. Don't
call me a sweeper. Don't you dare. Don't
you dare call me a sweeper, you son of a
bitch." I suppose it's possible that he
coincidentally got into a relationship
with a lolicon age player who posts
pictures of herself dressed as a baby on
Instagram because he liked her piercings
or her [__] hair color or some [__]
>> what is this?
>> Maybe he should just come out and say
that because I think there's still stuff
to litigate This is like an insane free
scroll. This is like crazy. Maybe he
should just come out and say that
because I think there's still stuff to
litigate here. There are questions that
need to be answered. I would like a
little bit more information on the
nature of this relationship before I
start sweeping for the man. I just want
to know why a guy who has a substantial
amount of his videography focusing on
the evils of lolicon is openly pursuing
a relationship with a girl who by his
own standards is a pedophile. Is that
not a pressing question to anyone else?
I feel like I feel like I'm taking
[__] crazy pills. The entire
commentary community has just
conveniently decided that this isn't
like objectively worse than Flamenco
jacking off the boy Soprano. Listen, I'm
sorry. If Tom had sex with this girl
>> Bungey for not dropping this angle, for
real, man. For real. For real. girl and
and she's into age play
>> come come on. Come on.
You know, you really want me You want me
to believe that Kai document You know,
you just read that Kai document. It's
like, I would never do age play. And you
You want me to go, oh, yeah. Sure. Okay,
Tom's cleared. That's what you're
expecting of me? That's [__] absurd.
maxing or something like that and she
dressed like a normal human being and
they had sex one time. It's not like a
sexually transmitted disease. This is
[__] crazy to me, okay? He's on the
stream going, "Well, if it's only a
one-time thing, then it's not bad." Can
you not just [__] ask him that? Why
are you speculating?
>> saying that was it.
>> Are you his lawyer? We do not know if it
was a one-time thing. We do not know
anything about this relationship or why
he was even attracted to this pedo in
the first place. All we know is that
this guy knowingly entered and pursued a
sexual relationship with a known lolicon
age player. Nick has a direct line of
communication. He doesn't ask any of
these pressing questions of his friend
who is potentially a massive file.
Instead, he just downplays it by saying
that all the girl did is wear Sketchers.
Then someone in Nick's chat literally
tells him to his [__] face that no,
she wasn't just This is so bad, dude. He
literally Nick is so [__] man. He's
so [__] stupid.
Just the the
just totally purposeless misplays that
he makes here are just bizarre. wearing
Sketchers. She's wearing a [__]
baby's binky in her posts. She had a
binky. Well, did she shove the binky up
Turkey Tom's [__] Is that what
happened? Don't know, Nick. That's the
whole point. We want to know what he was
doing with the girl who's doing the
[__] ABCs for pedos on Instagram. And
then to add insult to injury, in the
same stream,
>> This is like the most obscene lazy
sweeping I've ever seen.
Don't know, Nick. That's the whole
point. We want to know what he was doing
with the girl who's doing the [__]
ABCs for those on Instagram. And then to
add insult to injury, in the same
stream, this [__] fat [__] has the
[__] gall to cry over Chud Logic
calling him a sweeper.
>> And yeah, yeah, yeah, if you didn't
catch that
This is her sending like Instagram
messages to someone saying like, "The
ABC grind. You're not You're not allowed
to see the something dark, [__] up,
and twisted happen there."
Okay.
Wow.
Great really awesome stuff happening
here.
Instagram. And then to add insult to
injury, in the same stream, this [__]
fat [__] has the [__] gall to cry
over Chud Logic calling him a sweeper.
You are a [__] sweeper, you fat
[__] [__] Can any [__] watching
please explain to me how Nick
downplaying Ellie's age play is just her
wearing Sketchers on Instagram isn't him
openly [__] sweeping for Turkey Tom.
But because the age play has been
packaged alongside these other false
allegations, it allows Nicholas DeOrio
and the commentary community to just
sort of sweep it under the rug and
ignore it. As time goes on, you just
have to conclude that the VidCon
commentary meetup was basically like
sponsored by Jeffrey Epstein. It was a
Jeffrey Epstein production. POV you are
Augie RFC at the Diddy Con commentary
community meetup. Bowblax sitting
opposite you in a dress, his legs spread
open. Turkey Tom sitting in a diaper.
Nicholas DeOrio sitting in the kitchen
eating an entire jar of mustard and
peanut butter, getting incredibly gassy.
He's floating a couple of millimeters
off the ground because of how bloated
and gassy he is. I think a lot of people
who watch this won't have known anything
about the creepy order stuff because
there has been a clear and obvious
attempt from the commentary community to
downplay their relationship. Even Turkey
Tom in his response is talking about how
this is only a girl he briefly spoke to.
>> He's alleging that I did it with another
girl named Ellie who I briefly talked to
2 years ago.
>> Like dude, you sent her nudes. That's a
ridiculous downplaying of this
relationship. There's literally pictures
of you together. Even from the horse's
mouth, I mean, the DMs in his own video,
she's saying they [__] dated. And in
my mind, if it's nothing like Nicholas
DeOrio says, then why has there been
such a clear and obvious attempt to
downplay it? If it's a perfectly
reasonable, normal, fine relationship,
then why Then then you can Yeah,
exactly. Then you can present it exactly
as it happened and still defend it. Why
do you have to downplay it if it's
something you're totally fine with?
Is Nick lying saying she only wore
Sketchers? Why is Tom lying saying they
only briefly spoke? And look, if you
want to say that age play doesn't equal
pay,
that's all fine. But you know who
disagree? Every single [__] one of
these [__] A [__] all of them would
disagree. I mean, it's crazy. It's crazy
that this [__] is hanging in the [__]
air and they're all just ignoring it.
So, I already mentioned that the
coverage was bad, but who had the best
coverage? Well, according to the
commentary community, it was this fellow
called Sly Boy, whose video was I I am I
am glad there's just like a Sly Boy bit
in there. Sly Boy does just [__] suck
on like every level.
And more people need to be aware of
that.
>> Probably one of the more viewed. TommyC
says it's the best video he's ever seen.
>> Play with the 199. Thank you.
Who the hell is Sly Boy? He's the guy
who keeps fighting with pedophiles and
posting their doxes in his videos and
then cries when his videos get taken
down and says YouTube's siding with
pedophiles. He's like New Mama Max, but
uh with no filmmaking skill
and he looks like Brad Taste.
Seen. Seems fair. Seems fair. Wow, high
praise. I wonder what this guy said
about Ellie, the age play girl. Tom had
purchased really kawaii type gifts for
them, specifically Kuromi, which is like
a Hello Kitty type thing, as evidence
that he was, I guess, into age play and
wanted the girls he was with to be, I
guess, childlike. Overall, I think just
he bought me kawaii stuff, therefore
he's like in age play
quasi
pedophile type creep. I feel like that
is really flimsy and just bogged down
this whole thing
>> Buscemi eyelids, hasn't he? thing in a
way that's unnecessary. Oh, literally
[__] nothing. Hmm.
Intentionally leaves it out of his
video. Seems fair. Seems fair. What's
more than this is that Sly Boy here, who
of course made the best video, the most
well-researched video, he gets to Kai's
document, right? So, Turkey Tom's first
girlfriend made a document explaining
her side. Well, what does he say about
this document? Nothing. Why? Well,
because according to Sly Boy, it's not
possible to confirm that this document
was actually written by Kai. It
How [__] stupid would you have to be
to say this in a video?
How [__] stupid and lazy must you be?
searched video. He gets to Kai's
document, right? So, Turkey Tom's first
girlfriend made a document explaining
her side. Well, what does he say about
this document? Nothing. Why? Well,
because according to Sly Boy, it's not
possible to confirm that this document
was actually written by Kai. It can't be
done. Another detail to note, there is a
document being passed around that is
supposedly written by Kai, who is an ex
of Turkey Tom.
Um
I
have not been able to verify that she
actually [__] wrote this. She may
very well have. From what I understand,
she has zero social media presence, so I
don't know how to verify the
authenticity of this. The literal first
paragraph, and when I say paragraph, I'm
overselling it, it's actually the first
four lines, is Kai posting pictures of
herself that have never been posted
before to verify her identity. This guy
couldn't figure out how to do a [__]
reverse image search. And what's more,
if you just look at the [__] account,
she's posting selfies of herself months
prior. According to the commentary
community, this is the best video. This
is the best video on the allegation. A
guy who can't figure out how to do a
reverse image search is who they're
trusting to navigate rape allegations
now. Seems fair. I wouldn't trust this
guy to navigate a [__] corridor. This
guy would find a needle in a haystack
whilst searching for the [__] hay.
Honestly, it's [__] unbelievable. I
honestly wouldn't trust any of these
people to pass any allegations ever
again, by the way. If this is the
standard of research they're holding up,
good god. Honestly, if you want solid
coverage, you go to Chud Logic and you
go to Queenman. That's unironically just
Huge cosine. Huge cosine.
Say that cheese and right now. is who
you go to now. These allegations were
merely the beginning as they led to the
entire commentary community crumbling
into pieces over simple phrase. My
concern, ladies and gentlemen, is the
big sweep might be on. So, this guy
stuck a dagger right into my neck the
minute we stopped talking. He does not
>> No, that No, no, this is why I wanted
the video out, okay? I understand it's
easy to think I I tried it out of pure
narcissistic indulgence and that That is
part of it. However, no, this is really
why I wanted the video out. It's My
concern, ladies and gentlemen, is the
big
>> There's the second There's the second
half here. There's the second half of
this video. sweep might be on. So, this
guy stuck a dagger right into my neck
the minute we stopped talking. He does
not want to be challenged. He does not
want to be challenged on any of the [__]
that he's doing. Oh, he's extremely
vague on purpose so he can satiate his
audience, but also take no
accountability from me.
>> He is suckling shekels out of Ethan
Klein's [__] like nobody's [__]
business. And the moment someone starts
challenging him too much on it, he's cut
it off. It's done. Stop stealing his
screenshots. This Discord screenshots
now. Stop stealing his Discord
screenshots.
Dude, what the [__] dude? This is
unbelievable, bro.
This lined up perfectly with the
notorious fat drunk man, TommyC's
soothsayer prediction. Tommy's powers
first manifested when he witnessed his
father beating up his mother. His powers
manifested in that
and he predicted that this marriage may
be on the rocks. His future sight,
unfortunately, did not stop him from
being as a boy. You might be thinking,
"Well, how the [__] is a going to see
the future and still get his ass taken?"
I have a couple of possible options.
Number one, the most sinister option, he
Number two, the it was a more powerful
and experienced soothsayer using his
powers for pedophilia. And number three,
it was an unstoppable They They had all
the exits covered. There was no getting
out of it.
>> [laughter]
>> Dead or alive, he was getting
TommyC has hated Chud for a while
because using his psychic abilities, he
discovered that Chud, get this, was
lying about his working-class [laughter]
background and actually he's from old
money. Um I will say this, I do get the
fake that I I do get the sense that um
Chud is not like a working-class
Englishman. I wouldn't be surprised if
she Chud came from money, personally.
>> [laughter]
>> His dad's an oil baron. I actually have
a picture of Chud's father right here.
Tommy just
thinks that everyone with a formal
education is a liberal. He's [snorts]
going to PTA meetings like,
"What I got to do to get on this
>> [laughter]
>> special education? I heard little
Jaquain down the road from Liberia
speaking in clicks and whistles. They
put him on the special and my son just
getting the regular. This some DA
[__] is what it is."
Tommy, the special education is is for
children with learning difficulties.
"This some bullshit." He's slurring.
He's had a couple drinks on the drive
over. "Special
does not mean [__]
Special means good. I bet you're
thinking I'm special. Bet you're
thinking I'm [__] Fall for that
trick. In Nick's video, Why I Hate Chud
Logic, he lays out why he has no choice
but to rape Chud Logic. You see, over
the year Uh so, it's like that's like
all the bits that I do [laughter] every
day that I just keep referencing. Like I
literally could not stop over the last
like week or day.
been taking jabs at him, such as "The
big sweep might be on." Nick describes
these jabs as being akin to a sharp,
thin blade severing his jugular. The big
sweep might be on. Okay. We see it
again. [__] it, yeah. We'll play that
little 2-minute segment again. That's
just awesome.
This whole thing from where he starts
talking about Tommy's
is using his There was no getting out of
here. And number him being as a boy.
This is just awesome. His powers
manifested was first manifested when he
witnessed his father beating up his
mother. His powers manifested in that
moment and he predicted that this
marriage may be on the rocks. His future
sight, unfortunately, did not stop him
from being as a boy. You might be
thinking, well, how the [__] is it going
to see the future and still get his ass
taken? I have a couple of possible
options. Number one, the most sinister
option.
Number two, the there was a more
powerful and experienced soothsayer
using his powers for pedophilia. And
number three, it was an unstoppable They
they had all the exits covered. There
was no getting out of it. Dead or alive,
he was getting TommyC has hated Chud for
a while because using his psionic
abilities, he discovered that Chud, get
this, was lying about his working-class
background and actually he's from old
money. Um, I will say this. I do get the
fake that I I do get the sense that um
Chud is not like a working-class
Englishman. I wouldn't be surprised if
he Chud came from money, first of all.
>> His dad's an oil baron. I actually have
a picture of Chud's father right here.
Tommy just thinks that everyone with a
formal education is a billionaire. He's
going into PTA meetings like
Chud doesn't [laughter] even have a
formal education, does he?
Is it isn't Chud like
Did he even properly finish like
secondary school? I don't even know. Did
he do like
I feel like he probably finished
secondary school and then did an
apprenticeship or some [__] That seems
like Chud.
Got to do to get on this special
education. I heard little Jaquan Well,
if GCSE is formal education Speaking in
clicks and whistles, they put him on the
special. And my son just getting the
regular. [laughter] This some DA
[__] is what it is.
Tommy, the uh special education is is
for children with learning difficulties.
Yeah, you think I don't know that he
used a picture Jimmy Savile to to depict
Chud's dad? You think I didn't realize
that first time I watched this? You
really think that would pass me by?
>> And my son just getting the regular.
This some DA [__] is what it is.
Tommy, the uh special education is is
for children with learning difficulties.
This some [__] He's slurring. He's
had a couple of drinks on the drive
over. Special
does not mean [__] Special mean
Didn't
Chud's dad die of like a drug overdose
or something when he was like super
young? I swear that's something Chud
said. It's like so [__] funny that
Tommy said that he he comes from money.
Oh, I could be wrong. If people are
saying it's an overdose, I feel like
some people are saying he did. Some of
Chud's old heads are saying that. Maybe
he doesn't say specifically recently.
But I know his dad died when he was
young. I'm pretty sure that's true.
It's just like crazy to say, oh this
guy's lying about his working-class
background when he grew up on a council
estate and his dad died when he was
young.
It's like
how [__] [__] are you, dude?
Even just listening to Chud, how
[__] are you?
means good. I bet you're thinking I'm
special. Bet you're thinking I'm
[__] Fall for that trick. In next
video, why I hate Chud Logic, he lays
out why he has no choice but Chud Logic.
You see, over the year, Chud has been
taking jabs at Nick such as the big
sweep might be on. Nick describes these
jabs as being akin to a sharp, thin
blade severing his jugular. The big
sweep might be on, okay? The mid the big
sweep might
>> So this guy stuck a dagger right into my
neck the minute we stopped talking. I I
can't really take any of this seriously
because back in 2020, these guys every
day were saying that Tipster was
cheating on his wife, you know. Growing
up is realizing that Tipster actually
had the thickest skin in the entire
commentary community cuz they were
calling him unfaithful, they were
calling him a lolicon, a chaser. And to
him it was just all oil off a diddy's
back, you know what I mean?
>> You think Nick could have handled that?
He was crying over the big sweep might
be on. He probably would have topped
himself over this.
>> It's like you kicked Flamenco out of the
commentary community because you got
annoyed at Sal calling him a pedophile.
I mean, forgive me if I don't give a
[__] about your history on Nick's about
the big sweep is on. That's sort of the
entirety of the drama, by the way. I I
think the commentary community just
isn't used to being pressed by someone
who isn't either gay or mentally
disabled. He just clearly tried to paint
a lot of narratives about Chud being a
false accuser. I understand why he does
this because it looks quite pathetic to
just say, I hate Chud Logic cuz he hurt
my feelings. Anyone that wants to claim
that this is a nothing burger, okay? Why
the [__] is the podcast going on hiatus,
dude?
>> So my friend Tom is guilty because the
guy who was live when the allegations
dropped was confirming
the video until he knew it was
happening. Chud's point is in regards to
the severity of the allegations, not the
substance. Essentially, when the
allegations came out, a lot of people
were saying it was just basic
relationship grievances and not worth
talking about. They were saying that the
allegation was that Tom's gay and he
shoves [__] up his ass. And Tom, you
know, he never addressed that. So
realistically, that is still on the
table or alternatively, up the ass.
Chud's point is that obviously the
allegations were of some severity, else
Optics Cucked Diorio wouldn't have put
the podcast on hold. He's not saying it
proves he's guilty, he's saying it
proves the allegations are serious.
Interestingly enough It's obviously true
obviously true. This is a great angle.
This is a great angle and very true. And
the booking of Docster, the allegations
suddenly transformed from Tom having a
big hairy dick to life ruination. Change
your [__] tune on that one real
quick.
>> So then I start responding to him. This
is hours later after the video comes
out. And I go, right. And so he goes,
all the comments Not all the comments
were about you. He's been doing this for
quite a while. He's extremely vague on
purpose so he can satiate his audience,
but also take no accountability for me.
>> This is the point in the coverage where
I realize, oh, I didn't realize you were
having gay sex with the man. I was
unaware that you two were in a
homosexual relationship. I love that. I
love that. Imagine saying that to a
40-year-old man, by the way. You're
facing 30 and you're you're going to a
40 you're going to a 40-year-old man
saying, oh my god. You just can't find
accountability for me. Are you actually
a homosexual? Have I misread this whole
thing? Well, there's Bungi upload on his
Gumroad and on Nega Bungi. That's N Nega
Bungi.
I'm thinking I'm thinking I have no
choice but to assume that they are just
both gay. He really reveals a lot about
himself here. He's a homosexual and I'd
assume a bottom just from the nagging. A
lot of speculation on my part, but I'd
assume his ass is
from the DGG butt plug, which comes
standard as a member of the commentary
community. The Stone Masons had their
signet rings. Commentary community have
the engraved DGG butt plug, which
vibrates in Morse code and gives them
gives them talking points on stream.
Nick sits with his fingers over the
keyboard and he's hovering his fingers
over the letters and he goes,
And it spells out, support for Ethan
Klein is pivotal right now. Broadcast
straight from Tel Aviv. It's an ancient
order known as the synagogue of Steven.
After the big sweep is on incident, they
all met up in person wearing masks and
cloaks to preserve their anonymity. So
nobody can tell who's who if the cops
come sniffing around as they order 50
boxes of cheese pizza to Chud Logic's
council house. The major concerns with
Nicholas Diorio is that he is sucking
off Ethan Klein and Israel far too much.
And I think I'm a good person to cover
this because I am the most moral person
in drama, but simultaneously the least
principled. To be frank, I don't really
give a [__] because I don't watch him
and I never really have. Uh I think a
lot of people who are concerned are
either fans or friends. And to them it's
like it's like watching their son become
like a homosexual. I'm an empath, so I'm
I'm trying to put myself in Nicholas
Diorio's shoes and I'm thinking, if I
was spending $7,000 a week on food,
would I sell out to Israel? And
honestly,
maybe I would. Maybe I would. Very very
empathetic. Very empathetic. We love
empathy here. And now it has reached a
terminal level called Anisa Joma is
rating you on the Twitter timeline. It
starts with Anisa Joma doing an Ethan
Klein impression. I'm a big fan of
Nicholas Diorio. What can I say? You do
your research. And I saw a couple
people, you know, they were watching
this and they did a little laugh like,
haha. Diorio. What can I say? You do
your research.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude.
Oh, man. Sorry, you can't see his
avatar.
But behind my camera is the the stupid
[__] bird.
Is uh the stupid [__] bird.
>> people, you know, they were watching
this and they did a little laugh like,
haha. Diorio. What can I say? You do
your research.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude.
Come on.
Why are you pretending you find this
funny? Why are you demeaning yourself in
this manner? All that tells me is that
you fake Os.
You don't fight back. You just fake the
Os so you can go home and cry about it
in the shower like a like a ripped
loser. Nicholas Diorio, he doesn't do
the little laugh. He instead goes,
that's offensive. I'm a big fan of
Nicholas Diorio. What can I say? You do
your research.
>> the rapist is awesome, man. It's just so
good. I was just giggling to myself so
hard when I watched this, man.
I I made Jace to watch this. I made Jace
to watch this in an LP C.
I mean, I watched the whole video just
so I could make him watch that part.
loser. Nicholas Diorio, he doesn't do
the little laugh. He instead goes,
that's offensive. I'm a big fan of
Nicholas [clears throat] Diorio. What
can I say? You do your research.
>> [laughter]
>> Saying that Nicholas Diorio does good
research. I don't know. Not only is that
offensive, it's also bad. Like it's a
bad impression. He has stumbled upon the
rip
and he says, you cut that out right now,
buster. You stop raping that Israeli
woman right now. Support for Ethan Klein
is pivotal. Ethan Klein is being raped
by Anisa Joma. After this, he attempts
to post hoc rationalize it to the Chud
on Reddit by framing it as a hypocrisy
argument. But it's pretty [__]
obvious what he's doing. I mean, his
audience
>> Very true. women predominantly. He is
trying to signal to the fat women by
calling it offensive. He doesn't even
make a hypocrisy argument on stream, he
just calls it offensive and then that's
it. Anisa Joma catches wind of this and
she just calls him fat on the Twitter
timeline. And then his greatest ally
appears, girl with a microphone. And she
responds Thank god.
>> by calling Anisa fat phobic, to which
Anisa just calls her ugly.
I mean, [laughter] at this point at this
point, Nick, you know, are you just not
concerned?
Are you not concerned that the top that
the top guy here is a fat ugly lesbian
and Tech
2 3 years ago it's him and Orgy going
around talking about oh
You don't see people complaining about
getting harassed for having the wrong
opinions anymore. We must not be doing
our job properly. They said they are all
around that you saying Charlie. It's not
I don't think it's quite that. It's
something about copyright strikes or
something that's actually said about but
there is a quote that's like almost
exactly like that.
Um
and all this [__] That's like 2 3 years
ago. Now it's you'll be in fat phobic to
me. It's it's Nick and Liam going um
don't don't you think that's a little
fat phobic? Don't you think that's a
little fat phobic?
So crazy, bro. Tone. He has woken up in
a bed on Epstein Island. Tech Tone on
his left, Nux Taku on his right, Go with
a microphone lazing by his feet like a
pig. And he's not even leaving the bed.
That's the crazy thing. I don't know if
you you can't physically lift yourself
to leave or if you just don't want to.
Buns are a problem. Literally everyone I
know wears a bun a lot of days. It's
like they make the most innocuous things
into a problem.
>> It is like an abusive partner.
>> The code, bro. Dude, how do you not
watch that and think why the [__] have I
tangentially connected myself to a woman
who thinks that being called fat is akin
to being raped? You might think this is
bad enough that Anissa is calling you
fat and you have no comeback whatsoever.
But it got even worse because Anissa
tracked down an embarrassing clip of
Tonka Saw
Oh no. years ago. Tonka, when did the
tears come out of my eyes? I was crying.
>> When did the tears come out of your
eyes? Probably when that girl said she
wasn't your girlfriend on that post.
That was the saddest [__] I've ever
seen. What girl said she wasn't my
girlfriend on
>> posted a picture of you holding
somebody's hand
>> plays us in full.
>> to be vague about it and then they're
like you have a girlfriend and the
girl's like no no no, he's my best
friend. Did you have no idea what you're
talking
>> That was funny as [__]
>> It's hilarious.
>> No, that was funny as [__] Okay, so
that didn't happen, Nick. Nick, did that
happen or not? Yeah, it absolutely
happened. You posted a vague picture of
you holding somebody's hand or like
[__] some [__] and then they're do
you have a girlfriend? She's like no no
no, he's my best friend and not my
girlfriend. talk about my [__]
personal life on here. It's not your
personal life. It's a tweet you made.
It's a tweet you made, Nick.
Nick, it's a tweet you made. That's not
your personal life.
It's a tweet you made. It's not your
personal life.
It's a tweet, not your personal life,
dork. Oh, wow. You think it's cool to
talk I I intentionally don't name people
like this specifically cuz I keep that
part of my life very off the internet.
No, you don't. You try to post it and
look cool. And you didn't look cool. It
was her idea to make the [__] post in
the first place. I told him I'm sure it
was.
That's none of your [__] business.
Then why did you post it on Twitter,
Nick?
It's none of my business. Why is it up
there, Nick? Why did you post it if it's
none of anybody's business?
How is this your personal LIFE, NICK?
WHY DID YOU BRING IT UP IN A [__]
DEBATE, TONKA?
>> Because it's funny, remember? It's about
things that are funny. We're debating.
We're debating, Nick. Is that what's
happening?
Oh, DID NICK
>> [laughter]
>> I MEAN THIS IS JUST DEVASTATING AT THIS
POINT. I'M NOT even sure if he's going
to continue covering Anissa if she keeps
rapping him like this. So lastly, in
conclusion, Nicholas DeOrio needs to
stop being a fat. Turkey Tom needs to
take the diapers off. William Acker Show
needs to watch The Greatest Story Never
Told. Tommy C probably probably needs to
stop drinking, to be honest. And then
we'll be back.
You might be thinking what's he
muttering? What Okay. So huge bungee
video there. Hopefully you guys enjoyed
that.